STEPHANIE WONG: Hey, everyone.
We've got a special
episode of "Take5"
today, where we're going to
answer the top 10 questions we
hear from customers.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Wouldn't
that make it a "Take10?"
[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG: And
our first question is--
what exactly is a
customer engineer?
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Great question.
In a sentence,
customer engineers
exist to help our customers
transform, evolve,
and yes, engineer their business
applications on Google Cloud.
We do that by meeting
with customers
one-on-one to understand
their current state
and where they'd like
to be in the future.
We then work with customers
to navigate the best path
to get them from
today to tomorrow,
help identify the right
technical solution within GCP,
assemble a proof of
concept, collaborate
with them with a
proper architecture,
and design a migration plan
to safely and securely migrate
their data to its destination.
Our ultimate goal is to
help customers be successful
in Google Cloud platform.
And we really own that
end-to-end technical
relationship between
Google Cloud and you.
STEPHANIE WONG:
That's how we roll.
Question number 2-- if I want
to run my application on GCP,
how do I choose
which product to use?
NICK ORLOVE: Hmm.
That's a tough one because,
honestly, it depends.
I know that seems
like a cop-out answer.
But to recommend
where you should
be running your
application, it's
best to fully understand your
application requirements.
GCP offers four primary means
of application hosting--
those being Compute Engine,
Kubernetes Engine, App Engine,
and Cloud Functions.
Google Compute Engine,
or GCE for short,
is our infrastructure as
a service offering, which
allows you to
create fully managed
and customizable VMs
for running your apps.
If you're interested in running
a containerized application,
Google Kubernetes
Engine, or GKE,
might be the best
option, because GKE
Is our fully managed and hard
in container orchestration
and management service.
If managing the
infrastructure isn't your jam,
check out App Engine, which is
Google's platform as a service
solution, and lets
developers completely
focus on building
great applications
without the management overhead
of dealing with servers
or configuration deployments.
Finally, Cloud
Functions is Google's
event-driven and
serverless platform
that only runs your
code in response
to event-driven triggers.
The best news is you can also
pick a combination of computing
offerings.
So you don't have
to just rely on one.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: And I got one.
Now that we know about
application hosting,
my app obviously needs storage.
Question 3-- how do I decide
where to store my data.
STEPHANIE WONG: Well,
there are many fully
managed offerings here
for that data that's
either structured, unstructured,
transactional, or relational.
Persistent Disk
offers block storage
that's suitable for VMs
and any kind of containers,
like Google Compute Engine
or Kubernetes Engine,
as you mentioned.
Cloud storage is used
for object storage
and can store
streaming multimedia,
or custom data analytics
pipelines, or even backups,
and disaster recovery.
And then Cloud Bigtable is
a NoSQL wide-column database
that's suitable for real
time access and any kind
of analytics workloads that need
low latency and high throughput
read, write access.
Cloud Data Store is a
NoSQL document database
for Web and mobile applications.
And Cloud SQL is a manage MySQL
and Postgres database service.
Cloud Spanner is a mission
critical relational database
service with transactional
consistency and global scale.
And cloud BigQuery is a
fully managed Enterprise Data
warehouse with SQL
syntax and real time
response for ad hoc querying.
Lastly, we have a number
of databases and storage
used for Firebase, our mobile
and web app hosting platform.
NICK ORLOVE: Oh, hey,
a penny on the floor.
[WHOOSH]
IVAN RAMIREZ: I think
we took a wrong turn.
Oh well, onward with
question number 4.
Everyone is talking about
machine learning these days.
But I just don't know where
and how to get started.
What's the best way to get
started with ML if not a data
scientist or robot?
CORI PEELE: Well, Google wants
to democratize AI and make
it accessible and useful for
enterprises and developers.
We offer ready-to-use
models so you
can focus on the application
and not the science.
Using our machine learning
REST APIs is quite simple.
Google Cloud provides
fully trained machine
learning models for vision,
video intelligence, speech,
translation, natural
language processing.
And these are extremely
easy to use if you are
a developer familiar with REST.
So the ML APIs are
pre-trained on Google datasets
and ready to go.
Anyone that knows how
to call a REST API
can integrate with them
from their applications.
If you want to train
your own datasets,
instead of relying
on Google's data,
then Cloud AutoML
allows you to create
models specific to your domain.
No programming experience or
machine learning experience
is required.
You simply identify your
training data and labels,
and Cloud AutoML does the rest.
Lest we have the
world's most popular ML
framework, TensorFlow--
and this is available
as a managed service
called Cloud ML.
This is for those with
theoretical machine learning
knowledge and those who are
comfortable writing code.
Check out the blog
post, "Learn TensorFlow
and deep learning
without a PhD" if you're
a developer interested
in this option.
IVAN RAMIREZ: It sounds like
Google has a lot of experience
with big data and
machine learning.
Question 5-- if my
business is running on GCP,
does Google analyze the data
I've stored in the Cloud?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Not at all.
Many people are concerned
about their data.
And privacy is a
big deal for Google,
as well as every other company.
Our focus is on making sure only
you have access to your data.
Not only does Google not
read or analyze your data,
we also encrypt everything
and give you the ability
to use your own encryption
keys to make sure you're
the only one who can read it.
This applies to all of
the Google Cloud Services.
IVAN RAMIREZ: Thanks
everyone for watching.
Join us in the next episode with
the remaining top 5 questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]